allora posso spiegare non è
assolutamente quello che pensate però
devo farvi capire come siamo arrivati a
questo punto che è successo tutto
nell'arco di un'unica giornata partiamo
dall'inizio perché perché perché perché
perché questa cosa che ci caccia cos'è
allora sai copertina fare per un pò
video mai dong iva faq wega cosa che sto
facendo aiuto dj l'amico di approccio ma
cos'è gli anni fra te vieni ma no
il video di nikon d è un video si va beh
quanta cattiveria
lo schieramento attenzione contate
contate ma poi fanno i costumi di khost
le abbiamo lettori grosse elettori
grosse più grock se molto più grosse che
arrivate la tokyo tower rack e
bellissimo se non fosse che
esageratamente alta da non vedersi la
punta cioè nel senso la punta va oltre
le nuvole dove si trova probabilmente
anche goku allora ragazzi azzurri
abbiamo fatto una scommessa su quanto si
paga per l'entrata
secondo me non si paga non so perché
tanto ticket zio
se noi si paga alla si paga di euro 25
per arrivare al primo perché ci sono due
punti quei due bianchi che vedete il
primo in basso costa tipo 900 yen quello
più in alto costa 1600m quindi ha vinto
ha vinto sori
come al solito si apre le porte l'amato
guarda non esiste quindi adesso siamo a
250 metri di altezza ma in due minuti
porca vacca che figata assurda
bellissimo the kids storia quante case
quanta gente a tokyo quanto grossa
società cioè con la vista non ci arrivi
a vedere la fine vale che ci sono dei
grattacieli anche laggiù e ce ne sono
altri dietro probabilmente e questo è
solo una parte poi c'è anche la parte
opposta
ok ragazzi in tutto questo perso surreal
power non so che cazzo sia finito fuori
perché c'è un tema
ma quante cose qua dentro quanta roba
ali puoi scrivere delle cose delle quali
non me ne frega un cazzo qua c'è un ci
sono opposte dei videogiochi everywair
dove suri visto solo non ha visto
sorriso
amala ma porca [ __ ] anche io ti sto
seguendo i stavo girando intorno che è
bello stiamo salendo con le scale mobili
[ __ ] hanno fatto una torre di 200
mila metri non hanno i soldi a 45 finite
le scale dobbiamo scalare la torre
alcuni mosconi esatto ma c'è un altro
ascensore non potranno mettere un
ascensore per arrivare all'altro
ascensore anche bello ragazzi ci dovete
ammirare veramente quanto bella e questa
valvola di stupende che bello non me li
sono valvola così bella se non quella di
fianco piace alla bellissima tectonic
tutt'altro qua la pioggia li la prima è
che mi sto pagando addosso e soprattutto
per far cosa
e vabbè allora ct stronzi stato richiamo
sull'ultimo piano della tokyo tower il
gigantesco perché siamo molto tabla
screenate ragazzi screen a chi nel
quanti casi ci sono
quante persone stanno facendo sesso in
questa inquadratura e noi non le vediamo
piero angela sarà in mezzo a loro ed è
un addio ma aspetta esatto ciao un po
james bond
ad accompagnare solo ragazzi abbiamo
scoperto adesso che esiste la nota
window dove si può guardare giù vicino
alle toilette dove puoi pagare giu
ecco che da windows a giro che presa
male io lascio al telefono ti ho chiuso
gli occhi per dire del costo video ma
quando passano le macchine che figo soli
che cazzo ma tu sei fuori di testa
allora no no no no no no no no no no no
no no sentirlo ma chi è che ha messo sto
rumore estivo po di g no non ci ha fatto
che non ce la faccio non ce la faccio
non ce la posso fare perché non ho mica
go addosso sei scemo ora che c'è solo un
vetro c'è anche la rete a sei
completamente impazzito ma smettila di
saltare sulle cose
una volta sola basta e ti aspetta che lo
inquadra salta smetto il piede bene
metti che bene sopra tv al khadra che
era saldato
no no non ce la posso fare
basta voglio più fare niente del genere
ti stai calciando addosso a vuoi fare la
foto dai facciamo la foto come
bimbiminkia stessa ridona per quest'anno
panaro beh io non so con cose qualche
intervista facendo sta roba
macché che mai e che mai e maghetti
ragazzi devo dirvi questa roba non
potete capire cosa appena successo non
ho potuto fare video perché è successo
tutto in un attimo mi sono seduto per
mettere su chi souvenir nello zaino che
ho preso dei souvenir è arrivato un
bambino e mi ha dato questi dieci yen
credo mi siano caduti dalla tasca e
quindi il bambino li ha presi me li ha
portati mi ha fatto così questa è la
prima ipotesi la seconda ipotesi che
potrebbe avermi preso per un barbone beh
effettivamente uno che vestito così
potrebbe potrebbe solo essere un barbone
siamo usciti adesso dalla tokyo tower è
stata una cosa stupenda stiamo andando
adesso a dei pisu che praticamente un
altro quartiere di tokyo
perché dobbiamo incontrarci con i due
amici che abbiamo conosciuto all'ultra
japan che ragazzi annotato un sacco che
in giappone vanno pazzi per gli italiani
tipo roma italia surreal power antico
caffè andiamo fuori con caffè andiamo
fuori con caffè spinaci c'è scritto
spinaci caffè latte freddo cappuccino
vai barra la barra cioccolata anche un
bignè vigne e vini malattia cena con i
nostri amici giapponesi
la magica questa 4 punti manda versare
europa che ne metta papà piero volte in
più che mai
basta guardarsi da bere sto iniziando da
bere sa che mai lei per avere sarei mai
salvatore sanci provo sulla pa me l'ha
riempito di nuovo papà
no basta ma devi per me papà grazie papà
grazie papà l'ho fatto io ho bevuto io e
tanti basta farmi bene e basta
sono tutti ubriachi che cazzo sta
facendo giuseppe
[Applauso]
grandi case di piacere stare con voi
questa sera ciao mi chiamo ma che cazzo
dici
e qui siamo arrivati a questa cosa mi ok
non ho ben capito che cosa allora il
fatto è che c'è amore stare bene insieme
tutto il cast che vuoi ok però a un
certo punto cioè scolla di un attimo ci
hanno fatto bere ci hanno lo piano che
c'è mia madre di là ci hanno portati al
karaoke poi questa sardegna lasciam
perdere però è stata una serata
divertente ovviamente non è successo
niente niente quindi non fate anzi in
realtà una roba è successo a stefano si
è sentito male l'abbiamo portato via
perché stavamo invitando se non ci
credete c'è anche questo pezzo di video
che ha messo stefano sul suo canale li
faccio anche vedere come stava messo
perché vi era talmente messo male col sa
che è perché hanno fatto bene anche lui
che bloccava da ubriaco e io gli dicevo
spegne st videocamera che cazzo di
pagare se non bloccare il treno non
bloccare tanto lo taglia che cazzo ve lo
diamo tanto nota gli che cazzo ma cosa
stai bloggando più belle con svolgeva lo
stesso non so è stata una serata è stata
bellissima come serata tranne i ragazzi
questo era l'ultimo video per il
giappone spero che video vi sia piaciuto
è stato un viaggio indimenticabile ci
tornerò sicuramente il prima possibile è
stata una roba
wow veramente uomini treja spero che vi
sia piaciuto come al solito momento e mi
piace anche a causa di facebook e cavani
descrizione dei corsi di 16 picchiava
non fossero vito belle ragazze